how are you doing
i'm lovely how are you doing stephen i'm
doing excellent uh because i have a few
extra minutes with you
i like working in a few other types of
questions okay so
starting things off uh what tv series
would you love to guest star on
oh my that's a really interesting
question i haven't thought about that
recently i
oh god if there were another season of
mandalorian
mandalorian oh my god was so good but
there is
they're filming it next year
god i think i know what got it what what
movie or movies do you think you've seen
the most
oh my gosh that's hard um devil wears
prada's one and we're celebrating like
the 15th anniversary of it
legally blonde is another one i've seen
like a zillion times
um color purple i've seen a zillion
times those are like a few
sure you uh you produce if you could get
the financing to produce
anything tomorrow what would you make
and why
um i mean we have a couple shows that
we're trying to make right now
um i really want to do a story about
tracy african norman
and the trans woman who was a model in
the 70s who
was on a clairol hair color box in
stores
drug stores all over the country and no
one knew she was trans and when her
secret got out her career ended but then
she didn't give up that's incredible
i just interviewed her for my podcast
liver and talk show
incredible story that actually could be
really cool to see
um so i'm curious so getting into uh
jolt um so you take the project clearly
because you want to geek out with
stanley tucci about the devil wears
prada
and then you find out that you really
don't have any scenes so
were you like storming off the set on
what day what happened
well i yes i knew i didn't have any
scenes with him but i did i
had one scene and he was lovely i did
not mention double wars prada
but obviously i girded my loins
um stanley was one of the reasons but
bobby was one of the reasons kate was
one of the reasons
daniel westler our director was a huge
reason and the script was a reason and
i've never done an action film
i love the comedic elements of it um
i needed comedy in my life at the time
um
and i got to do some things i haven't
done before and that is
really important to me as an artist and
um i i love action movies i've loved
fashion movies for really long times
like
so happy i get to be i love learning
about the behind the scenes of the
making of a movie
so what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of jolt
wow um when we shot in london
in sofia bulgaria um i don't know that
would surprise people
what i didn't know is that whenever you
have a gun
on camera um you have to the um you know
munitions
expert or whatever comes and makes sure
and shows the gun is not loaded
um every time um you know anyone has a
gun
and that that's because there was i
think it was a movie called the crow
there was an actor who was shot
um during that film like
so we have those protocols now in place
because of that and i didn't i didn't
know that
because i'd never done a film like this
um so i don't know if the general public
knows that but
yeah no i i think a lot of people don't
realize the safety precaution
i think a lot of people actually don't
know uh casual fans what really goes on
on the movie set and how it's
maybe not as luxurious and glamorous as
maybe some people might think
it really it often isn't i mean like
there's so many
there's so many moments with that are
just you have to get in
the muck and and it's muck and it's you
know and it's
and it's in a lot safety is huge so
safety is like hugely important
with everything on a set i mean anything
can happen i mean like there's equipment
all over the place and this equipment's
falling on people people got injured
so safety is a huge issue and you really
want to make sure you're with people and
working with
a team who's really attuned to that and
looking out for your safety
um safety first really what's the secret
for playing a good detective on film
i i don't know i i don't know i mean
i don't know if i i did it well or not
but i know i had a ton of fun
i know that i um love
that angela is you know cursed like a
sailor it was really foul mouth but i
understand that that's like a defense
because she works in a mostly male
environment and she wants to be taken
you know seriously not effed with not
[ __ ] with i'll just curse
and i but i love that she's really
serious about the job and she's she
she likes order and so this this whole
thing about rules and order
it's really i found really interesting
for her and
um i think it's like it becomes this
code for her in a really chaotic world
um police detectives see a lot of crazy
intense stuff
and so i think like rules kind of help
like ground
her and probably other you know police
officers in real life in something that
is
a really chaotic world that doesn't
always make sense
i am looking forward to shonda's next
series inventing uh anna
uh what can you tease about that project
and who you play
oh i had so much fun i play casey duke
who is a a personal trainer
and a life coach she is a real life
human being and
in this inventing and it's based on the
real life story of anna delvey
aka anna sorensen who sort of um was
just the fake heiress who made the
tabloids a
number of years ago here in new york she
was um she
sort of said she conned the you know
sort of socialites of new york city
and um she was a con woman who was
um this really fascinating story julia
garner who
plays her is stunning i did a movie with
julia um grandma in like 2015 and she
was brilliant in that
and obviously ozark is like her body of
work
over the years is just incredible and
she's so young
and as anna she's insanely good
she's funny and she's just
there was this one scene where i was
just like
julia is just deep like julie is a
really deep actress and she has a deep
understanding of like human psychology
and behavior
for fans of shonda's work how do you
think it compares to previous projects
or is it something completely different
that's a good question i'm a fan of
shonda's work and
it feels really different than her other
work it feels really different than the
other projects it's not bridget and it's
not
scandal it's not private practice it's
not great it's something
very different tonally but like but
it's the table reads and i knew what was
gonna happen
but the table reads you're like on the
edge of your seat because it's
so she has a way of writing
that just pulls you in and you can't you
can't look away
and you want to know what's going to
happen next and then you can't believe
what's happened next
even when it's based on a true story and
you read the you know new york post
article on it or whatever new york
you know new yorker gifted
shonda's gifted within the whole team of
writers and directors it was a really
good group of people
and i got to keep the clothes
is that now in the contract first time
it's not in my contract but sean delane
is very generous and um
lynn who works with wardrobe is
incredible and i got to wear some
awesome clothes and i got to keep
a lot of them and i'm very excited
the real perk of the gig um i am a big
fan of james spader
and you got to work with him on
blacklist uh what was that experience
like
uh uh i'm i'm curious what that was like
i'm a ginormous fan of james spader
since pretty
in pink even though he was a horrible
and awful person in pretty in pink
i am a huge fan of boston legal was at
this i mean i want to know someone
that's just um
his all his credits he's incredible and
i was very nervous to work with him but
i love the show
and um they i um they reached out to me
to um do a guest spot like a couple of
years ago and i was
i started with the fourth season and
started watching and i was like oh this
is cool but like i didn't really get
what was going on and they like
approached me
with um dr perillos and i was like oh
this is really good and so i had some
time
so i started from the first season and i
was like
i'm blown away by the show first of all
i don't know if you're up to date with
what's going on
and the season finale is tomorrow
i love that show and spader is so
he's an executive producer so what was
amazing for me about watching him work
because i produced an
active before but i have to take the
producer hat off he
was able to be in the scene but then
also
notice what's going on and with it with
the with the tv screen right and he's
aware of like what's going on instead
and what makes sense and what doesn't
make sense and so he's
very much producing while he's acting
which
is i can't i don't know how he does it
honestly um
i guess he's just been doing it for a
very long time he is um
really really specific um
very specific about what he wants and he
knows what he wants
but and it's it's just really clear i
mean it's like
some actors play and they try different
things and he knows exactly what he
wants to do
and he's very generous too he's very um
[Music]
i mean red writing is intimidating um
but he
is james is a pussycat and he's really
sweet
and um but i but you have to earn it
you have to earn it gotta stop i have to
stop there i'm just gonna say congrats
on everything
i wish you nothing but the best good
luck with the rest of your speed dating
today
thank you stephen